desperate of news of family and friends
people queue outside the hospital in the
city of Carmen inside the injured
filling hospital beds and being treated
in its corridors what had begun as a day
with large numbers of people turning out
to pay their respects to an assassinated
commander ending with more death in the
streets of his hometown several hours
after the funeral of Qasem Soleimani
began on Tuesday morning there was a
stampede among the crowds the procession
turning into a crush and desperate
efforts to save the lives of people
where they fell the small city unable to
deal with the vast numbers that have
converged on it Iranians from across the
country had made their way to c'mon for
what was supposed to be Salaam on his
final procession well if you come here
because I love general Soleimani
I am a swinging from Bandar Abbas and we
want to show that we are also here for
him this is something small I can do for
general Soleimani just to come here and
even though he's not with us
his philosophy continues so the money
had requested to be buried in his home
city alongside those that had died
fighting in the iran-iraq war during the
1980s he was killed in a US air strike
in Iraq last Friday and people are still
calling for revenge the head of Iran's
Revolutionary Guard made this promise Oh
sham I'm saying the final word first we
will avenge harshly be certain be calm
we are telling the enemy we will avenge
if you respond we will burn that place
you love and they themselves know where
it is
politicians gathered in Parliament
declaring death to America no compromise
no surrender and revenge and voting to
designate the Pentagon and US forces
terrorist organizations all those who
ordered as well as the perpetrators of
this crime who are with the Pentagon in
their military are counted as terrorists
for four days crowds have taken to the
streets to honor and pay their respects
to Qasem Soleimani the tragic events of
Tuesday and Carmen have added even more
grief before Iran decides to take its
next move aside big Al Jazeera Tehran